[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
de l'éducation telle initiative des
enseignants met-il en place pour
transmettre toujours plus et toujours
mieux comment vos enfants intègrent
eut-il les savoirs et les valeurs de
l'école toutes les réponses sont dans
liberté égalité scolarité et voici tout
de suite le sommaire
puis la réforme du baccalauréat les
lycéens doivent présenter en fin d'année
le grand oral comment les élèves s'y
prépare la réponse dans un lycée
parisien
puis direction la montagne et les
pyrénées très exactement là bas pendant
les vacances on s'amuse tout en révisant
je vous emmène en colo apprenantes il
n'était pas le meilleur des élèves un
peu trop facétieux mais c'est à l'école
qu'il a rencontré ses copains du
splendid gérard jugnot nous racontera
ses mémoires d'école comment intéresser
les plus jeunes à la lecture une école
primaire de grenoble à développer ses
recettes on ira tourner quelques pages
avec eux et pour finir de l'art dans les
classes comment l'éducation artistique
et culturelle s'est intégrée dans les
programmes au fil du temps
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle épreuve du
baccalauréat depuis la session 2021 les
élèves de terminale doivent répondre aux
questions d'un jury c'est le désormais
célèbre grand oral cinq minutes d'exposé
sur un sujet dix minutes des changes
avec les membres du jury pour
approfondir le thème et les cinq
dernières minutes plus personnelles sont
réservés aux projets d'orientation du
candidat alors pour s'y préparer au
mieux voici les trucs et astuces du
lycée molière
[Musique]
bonjour
enfants
valérie à partir d'aujourd'hui je vais
vous proposer des ateliers qui vont vous
permettre et bien d'appréhender les 20
minutes que vous allez passer devant le
jury on va apprendre à mémoriser son
exposé parce que je le rappelle nous
n'avons pas le droit aux notes vous
devez arriver sans aucun support devant
le jury donc on va faire l'entraînement
avec alexandre et eloïse donc alexandre
pas s'entraîner héloïse va le film est
alors ça c'est important pour que
alexandre puisse se revoir à la maison
c'est une forme de média training
exactement bonjour alors aujourd'hui
vous parler des enjeux sanitaires et
médicaux de la conquête spatiale
pourrait être amené à se demander si la
médecine et l'espace ou deux mois à
compter spatiale
que veux tu être complémentaires dans
leurs démarches
3 minutes 30 tu t'es chronométrés ou pas
des grandes métropoles ensuite est
chronométré à peu près dans ma tête
alors justement il faut penser que le
jour où il vit on a tendance à accélérer
le rythme donc et on oublie des choses
souvent donc c'est un peu plus
raccourcis et là le jury il est très à
cheval sur le chronomètre vraiment on va
pouvoir passer à un autre atelier celui
de dialoguer avec le jury on va faire un
petit jeu de rôle et on va se mettre à
la place du virus mais mon sujet c'est
la déforestation de l'amazonie un enjeu
mondial dans le monde donc là masoni
c'est une région située en amérique du
sud qui est traversée par le fleuve le
plus important du monde donc l'amazone
alors le jury
pour pat a choisi ce sujet est ce que tu
pourrais me rappeler ce que c'est que la
notion de développement durable
cal politique balle scénario entretien
parle à 28 et pour finir est ce que tu
pourrais me dire ce que c'est que
l'anthropocène qu'est ce que tu fais en
cas de grosses questions pièges bah
c'est vrai que je vais demander
peut-être de reformuler la question est
de passer sur quelque chose que je
connais mieux pour pouvoir répondre ok
ils sont bien préparés aux élèves un
bien préparé merci
sujet c'est quoi
dans la compassion
ok faton sujet ses bras
comment la littérature cadavres en cause
de danse de la guerre ok génie et toi
moi quand j'ai beaucoup plus précis
c'est la disparition du glacier
chacaltaya en bolivie ok un patrimoine
naturel menacé ok est ce que vous
trouvez bien d'avoir une épreuve comme
ça complètement à l'oral sans notes sans
feuilles sans stylo savouré l'or au
monde du travail parce que les crises et
bien c'est bien de savoir bien écrire ça
peut servir pour des concours mais
l'oral dans le monde du travail c'est
quelque chose qui est super important on
va devoir passer des entretiens
d'embauché et vous pensez avoir combien
allez on fait des petits poèmes situé
près aussi on vision visé combien font
aller 17 15 19 vous payer un café serré
résultats ok
et si vous avez plus
moi je laisse travailler alors un autre
atelier les cinq minutes orientations du
grand littoral ce qui vous a aidé à
faire vos choix sur parcours sup je me
suis renseigné j'ai fait des recherches
sur les formations ça il faut le dire à
lévis stella
tout d'abord je me suis intéressé très
jeune à mon projet d'avenir est ce que
je voulais faire plus tard donc dès la
troisième j'ai commencé à faire des
portes ouvertes des écoles de commerce
et puis récemment j'ai pu m'engager dans
une association qui s'appelle l'histoire
de climate et qui défend la lutte
environnementale et la justice
climatique
voient comment dans dix ans
je me vois
femme d'affaires
non je ce qui est sûr c'est que je
voudrais vraiment avoir des
responsabilités à grande échelle on peut
là faut dire je pense
parce que si vous me faites ça le jour
du grand oral je serai ravi
bravo stella est ce que est ce qu'on a
le droit de pas savoir ce qu'on veut on
veut voir la motivation de l'élève on
n'a pas envie de voir un élève passif en
moi je sais pas ce que je veux faire non
il faut qu'ils nous montrent même s'il
ne sait pas encore qu'il est en train de
réfléchir à son projet et qu'il y
travaille est-ce que vous vous sentez
prêt
oui vous allez tout savoir la moyenne
mais c'est ça qu'on veut les entendre on
fêtera ça tous ensemble après
merci beaucoup merci nous avoir
accueillis merci et mon dernier conseil
ayez confiance en nous
[Musique]
je parle doucement parce qu'on est dans
le train direction les angles dans les
pyrénées aux parents colo
les colonies de vacances c'est
l'occasion de se faire plein de copains
de découvrir des activités sportives et
culturelles de faire des batailles de
polochons dans les dortoirs oui mais ici
aux angles on n'oublie pas complètement
l'école cours de français et de
mathématiques ont révisé fondamentaux on
remobilise les savoirs tout en s'amusant
bienvenue dans une colo apprenantes
[Musique]
et
ce matin on va définir ce qu'est une
affiche publicitaire on va l'analyser et
une fois que vous aurez toutes les clés
dans un deuxième temps vous allez en
produire in l'objectif c'est que ça
colle à votre vécu de la semaine alors
on a essayé de travailler sur une
affiche particulière c'est une houle h
ma femme est logique que nous sommes en
montagne de travailler sur effectivement
la vache milka
est ce que vous y voyez tout ça où tu
t'appelles comment toi cardio
[Musique]
est alors toi tu viens on trouve la
chanson
c'est rigolo venir à l'école en
chaussons
bah oui c'est pas l'école normale parce
que c'est quoi ici en fait c'est
[Musique]
une colo vous apprenez des choses assez
super ça je vais mettre entre vous deux
salut les filles
donc là vous êtes en vacances à l'école
c'est un peu bizarre non
la fois fallico on fait des jeux 20
partir des jeux mais c'est pas du vrai
travail comme est ce que pendant la
période du coc vite vous avez eu la
sensation d'être clos 1 de l'école ne
pas avoir les cours tout le temps
c'est bon je m'en vie dans mon école on
n'était pas beaucoup les boxes et pas de
bisous ouais donc c'est cette voix si
elle voit le matin j'étais tout seul et
février nous avons
je vous laisse tranquille ans on se
donne 10 15 opposants
[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous accueillir aux
angles magnifique station pour des
vacances apprenantes expliquez-nous un
petit peu comment est née cette idée de
vacances apprenantes alors les vacances
à prenantes
c'est une idée qui est née
au début du premier confinement au
printemps 2020 où on a constaté
combien les enfants avaient une
scolarité perturbée et pour beaucoup
étaient en décrochage pour beaucoup
c'est plus de 10% des enfants les
enfants qui sont accueillis ici sont
choisis sur les critères qui sont nature
sociale des enfants qui sont encadrés
par ailleurs dans le cadre de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance des enfants qui ont
été repérés pour devoir être accompagné
un peu plus que d'autres voilà un petit
peu tous les critères qui prévalent à
l'accueil de ces enfants
concrètement comment tout cela et
financier alors la formule vacances
après vente est initié par le
gouvernement elle est portée par
l'éducation nationale elle est financée
par l'éducation nationale dans presque
sa totalité les vacances apprenantes ça
devrait durer tout le temps tout vendait
pour tous les enfants
on va faire un texte pour raconter aux
copains en fait mais ce que vous avez
vécu mardi matin pour appeler ce qu'on a
fait
la ferme du rial et c'était quoi ça
[Musique]
pédagogique très bien qu est ce que vous
avez appris
les enfants
bonjour est ce que ce serait chouette si
l'école c'était tout le temps à la
montagne avec des activités
très bien que l'école soit tout le temps
comme ça la tendance il faudrait bien
provisy ah oui c'est vrai faudrait pas
que ce soit tout le temps la montagne
faudrait que ce soit la moitié de
l'année à la montagne la moitié de
l'année à la mer
l'école du monde c'est un très joli nos
bons mais les enfants je vous félicite
parce que vous avez vraiment très bien
travaillé ce matin vous avez fait de
beaux textes et je suis fière de vous
c'est vraiment du pain béni parce qu'on
va partir des activités que les enfants
où vécut collectivement pour construire
des apprentissages avec eux donc on
donne vraiment du sens aux
apprentissages et du coup on arrive à
avoir une classe où tous les élèves sont
motivés pour produire est-ce que vous
pensez que ce type de dispositif peut
aider à rattraper un peu de l'impact
qu'a eu le co lead sur la scolarité de
ses élèves oui déjà moi je pense que ce
qui a fait le plus de mal pendant attal
qu'ovide c'est le fait que les élèves se
soit coupé socialement donc là justement
on est dans son rattrapage puisque c'est
des enfants la plupart ne se connaissent
pas ils viennent d'horizons différents
donc ça il apprécie énormément donc je
pense que le travail et le vivre
ensemble au cours de ces colonies
apprenantes c'est un gros gros bénéfices
eh bien merci beaucoup et puis nous
maintenant on avait été on ira tout de
suite mais bon courage
[Musique]
qui c'est qui veut un petit coup de main
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
j'arrête le vélo je me préparais pour la
boum
qu'est ce que toi tu as retenu des cours
est ce que ça t'a aidé sur certains
trucs comme exemple le théorème de
thalès en fait ça m'a permis
d'approfondir si ce sujet la vie grâce à
la colo apprenantes a pu réviser en fait
le job en baisse c'est ça
bon ça va le pape fera ouais super bon
alors on est prêt pour aller danser oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'un de nos plus célèbre comédien
il est passé par tous les registres il
nous a beaucoup fait rire et nous a émus
il a aussi fait chanter les enfants du
film les choristes maintenant gérard
jugnot va nous raconter ses propres
souvenirs d'école suivez-moi
[Musique]
bonjour gérard jugnot bon je vois ne me
pèse vous étiez quels types d'élèves
médiocre c'est vrai
médium et j'ai beaucoup lu sur mes
carnets peut mieux faire ah
c'est vrai que j'aurais pu mieux faire
je me reconnais pas six ans 5 6 ans
ouais ouais pas plus à l'école primaire
déjà et j'aime préparer petit cinéma
n'est que moi je vais en institut est
magnifique ça ne me sentir qu'ils
étaient quand à elles changé ma vie je
vraiment c'est un type passionnant et en
plus il avait une méthode assez drôle
c'est qu'en fait on travaillé pendant
une heure 55 minutes et les cinq minutes
qui restent il fallait des connaissent
les réalités et après ils mettaient un
élève comme prof et il fallait que cette
f se fassent l'échec ou non savas
écoutez donc m'intéresse c'est les
membres alors qu'on lui balance et les
truites dans la tranche c'était assez
passionnant c'est assez rigolo exercices
marqués rires c'était ya quelques années
qu'est ce que cela vous a apporté
l'école
de rencontrer des gens j'ai rencontré
d'ailleurs
les gentils sont encore des amis avec
qui on a fait une grande route c'est
clavier fait rencontre en cinquième
michel blanc quatrième thierry pareil et
c'est vrai que je dois beaucoup à ce que
c'est c'est là où j'ai commencé à faire
des défier où ça j'ai commencé chez les
scouts affamés petit simon et en double
8 mm et au château club théâtre on a
monté dans deux spectacles ça a commencé
en 68 quoi et les profs vous vous
souvenez à ce moment là c'était d'aider
des profs wild qui connaissait un petit
peu vos vos activités qui m'ont
beaucoup parce que on est on lèche a été
beaucoup c'était très belle lauriers
parce la joie cette photo là c'est un
jeu c'est pendant soixante
406 alors montrez moi veut c'est 66 je
le sais tu écris peut-il ouais c'est ça
et ce professeur était professeur
d'histoire s'appelle monsieur propos
monsieur propos quand on a un nom comme
ça on change
sinon c'est catastrophique c'est un
groupe compliqué et donc je lui deux
années de suite et le pauvre il a aidé à
morfler normalement j'essaye de vous
trouver c'est facile vous pensez vous
pas j'avais des cheveux
non si c'est là c'est important
d'apprendre et l'école c'est quand même
un enfant on peut apprendre on peut dire
des conneries sans être tout de suite
jugé et on peut essayer on peut se
comprendre on n'est pas obligé on peut
se tromper d'ailleurs c'est ça c'est
comme les répétitions théâtre c'est fait
pour se tromper les cours d'art
dramatique c'est fait pour ceux d'abord
pour rencontrer aussi d'autres genres
mais c'est pour se tromper et 100 à 100
est de juger on n'est pas sur une scène
des gens pas payés et non pas vous le
sifflet on se nourrir et l'école c'est
aussi ça c'est là où on peut se tromper
merci infiniment gérard jugnot d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
[Musique]
comment favoriser l'apprentissage et la
pratique de la lecture dès le plus jeune
âge tous les enseignants de france
défendent cette grande cause nationale
et vous allez voir qu'ici à grenoble de
nombreuses initiatives ont été mises en
place dans l'école primaire des jeunes
est classé r est plus la lecture est
parfois très éloignés des petits
écoliers pourtant du cp au cm2 ici tout
le monde lit et même avec plaisir
[Musique]
de l'apprentissage de la lecture ça
commence dès le cp suivez moi dans la
classe de bac du bois c'est bon pour la
musique vous allez roger des cahiers on
passe à la lecture on va s'installer là
le géant de zéralda
cacher derrière quelques rochers bordant
le chemin l'ogre attendait la fille est
prêt à se jeter sur elle ah voilà enfin
un petit déjeuner marmonne-t-il
je m'arrête là pour aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que l'apprentissage de la
lecture et on insiste beaucoup avec eux
depuis le début de l'année c'est non
seulement des chiffres et des mots mais
aussi les comprendre ce qu'on peut être
un très bon décodeur et connaître tous
les sons mais l'idée c'est de comprendre
ce qu'on lit donc on travaille quand on
lit et soi même le texte et pour
s'entraîner on s'entraîne aussi à
écouter des histoires
[Musique]
e
m
tes jambes à leur cou cache toi
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire
on lui conseille de prendre ses jambes à
son cou ça veut dire qu'elle soit très
vite court très vite courir très vite on
remarquait avec les plus grands même
avec les plus petits que les premiers un
livret remis à leur place l'iran prenait
mais il n'allait jamais vraiment
jusqu'au bout il ne faisait pas ses
efforts de prendre le temps d'essayer de
comprendre le livre et depuis qu'on mène
cet atelier là ils prennent plus le
temps dire qu'ils prennent un livre on
s'accorde dix minutes et on reste sur ce
livre ils prennent plaisir à prendre le
temps il arrive que dans votre classe en
enfant vous dix mois la maison du livre
bah oui bien sûr ni grève ni style
boyish outre les crimes aux couleurs
mais on essaie de donner ses habitudes
la aux enfants en tout cas ils sont ils
ont envie danser sur un chat il ya aucun
enfant qui voudrait qu'il n'a pas envie
d'aller à la bibliothèque
je mets chronomètre pendant combien de
temps qu'un pique nique 15 minutes et
c'est parti
et bien choisi l'histoire tu veux venir
nous et
[Musique]
commença plus si
c'est un temps où les élèves y lisent
tout seul donc ils choisissent soin de
lire vraiment tout seul dans un coin
comme on peut en voir certains il y en a
qui peuvent être allongée s'installe
vraiment où ils veulent dans la classe y
en a d'autres qui lisant groupe aussi
c'est pas un temps que scolaire on doit
être assis à sa place on répond à la
maîtresse c'est vraiment un temps qu'il
faut rendre sympa quoi
[Musique]
nous allons vous lire un livre qui
s'appelle mon petit papa fait des
cauchemars
tu as du mal à dormir peut-être que tu
as envie de faire pipi j'ai encore fait
un cauchemar
ça s'est bien passé alors pas trop
stressé moi j'ai assisté à la lecture
c'était super ah non vraiment bravo
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de
servir vos cm2 devant des élèves de cp
ont trouvé que c'était intéressant que
les petits veaux aussi les grands qui
lisent qui disent très bien même qui
s'entraîne on est vraiment dans le
plaisir et je pense qu'à l'école c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est hyper
important on parle beaucoup d'apprendre
à prendre mais je pense que la prendre
avec le plaisir ci est la base de tout
et moi je le vois les sourires qu'ils
ont que je vois bien que ça vient d'eux
c'est à dire j'ai pas besoin de leur
dire allez vous prenez le livret vous
entraîner c'est vraiment une approche
qui fait que tout le monde est en
réussite
[Musique]
et
aujourd'hui l'éducation artistique et
culturelle est une évidence de la flûte
au cours d'arts plastiques tous les
élèves peuvent approcher même pratiquer
un art mais vous allez le voir ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas c'est notre
capsule old school préparé par le réseau
canopée
jouer d'un instrument peindre dans c'est
que ce soit à l'école ou lors d'une
sortie ce qui sonne aujourd'hui comme
une évidence de l'éducation artistique
et culturelle n'a pas toujours été
acquis petit coup d'oeil dans le rétro
c'est avec jules ferry en 1880 que
l'école commence à enseigner des
pratiques artistiques mais peu valorisé
celle ci n'arrive qu'en dernière
position des programmes scolaires après
les travaux d'aiguillé des jeunes filles
et ça n'évolue pas pendant près d'un
siècle une émission de la série
l'atelier à l'école consacré à la
décoration d'un volume voici quelques
travaux qui ont été faits par vos
camarades parisiens
résultat jusqu'à la fin des années 60
les élèves n'auront droit qu'à deux
heures de musique et de dessin par
semaine et à de très rares sorties
culturelles déconnecté des programmes
mais à partir de 1968 la culture
commence à être considéré comme une
composante du développement social et
l'école est vu comme le moyen le plus
démocratique d'y accéder en dépit des
inégalités une éducation artistique se
dessine alors
intégrée à l'enseignement général et
démarrer dès le primaire mais surtout
elle doit se prolonger hors de l'école
et privilégier le contact avec les
artistes
je traite il faut s'appliquer
j
[Musique]
l'un des premiers chantiers de cette
révolution vise à rapprocher les
différents acteurs ministère de
l'éducation nationale de la culture mais
aussi collectivités associations
institutions culturelles et artistes se
réunissent au sein d'instances
d'orientation dès lors les protocoles
d'accord se suivent tous les cinq à dix
ans pour renforcer cette coopération
en 2000 le plan langue basque à marque
une étape importante les enseignements
artistiques sont confortés de la
maternelle à l'université les programmes
s'adapte pour faire place à plus de
pratique et la majorité des
établissements culturels se dote des
kits de médiation envers le jeune public
sur le terrain les enseignants sont de
mieux en mieux formés dès le départ puis
tout au long de leur carrière pour les
élèves le changement est flagrant d'une
relation jusqu'à leur distante et
cantonné à la classe les enfants
découvrent les oeuvres sein des musées
et théâtres dialogue avec les artistes
et expérimentent les processus créatif
le nombre d'enseignements artistiques
s'enrichit avec l'histoire des arts les
arts du cirque le cinéma et cetera la
danse apporte aux élèves de la confiance
en soi de l'estimé de soi un espace de
liberté aussi puisqu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de liberté dans la création et
se construisent en fait à la danse
aujourd'hui les élèves peuvent
s'exprimer artistiquement à travers de
nombreux dispositifs et les musées
centres d'art contemporain théâtres et
salles de concerts sont devenus des
partenaires indispensables de l'école
face aux inégalités issues de
l'environnement social et familial
l'école a un rôle unique à jouer pour
permettre à chaque élève d'accéder à la
culture de ressentir et de pratiquer un
art et ainsi de se réaliser comme
individu tout en comprenant l'autre
et voilà les missions et déjà terminée
mais on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro de liberté égalité